you know what else keeps me awake at  night  if you go back to like the year 1900 and  asked people what do you fear most about  the future of civilization and you get  all manner of answers one would be  tuberculosis  another would be population without  would outstrip the food supply so  there's a list  of what people worried about you know  something in the year 2000 none of those  things are on anybody's list and a whole  set of other things are like climate  change and and  you know uh asteroid strikes all kinds  of things that were not even known about  a hundred years earlier so you know what  i worry about  what on our list today  would be of no concern to anyone  in the year 2100 because we learn about  other stuff that can kill us  that right now we are just oblivious to  that scares the daylights out of me